a couple that groove together stays
together
that is Jenna Dewan Tatum and Channing
Tatum celebrating the 10-year
anniversary of the movie step up which
by the way is today and this is a movie
that gave us the birth of that
relationship right in front of our eyes
I don't know how we would have done the
movie without it I really don't catch me
on the set we had such a great time I
mean it was like instant chemistry for
two of us we could totally see it from
their first ever onscreen kiss to every
dance move they did together and when we
talked to them back in 2006 Jenna was
all about Channing it was just like he's
such a doll he's such a great guy like
he just won the Thai people you just
want to be around so we had a great time
the couple actually met when Jenna
screen-tested for her role in the dance
classic they started dating after the
film wrapped and walked the red carpet
together for the premiere we're having
the time of our lives I mean we got to
dance we got to fall in love it was long
before he showed off his Magic Mike
moves Channing was gushing about his new
love she made me look good all I had to
do is just stand there and be like
someone to catch her and lift her and
stuff and just her doing all the type of
stuff yeah I got off easy woman you
didn't you know when you're rehearsing
every day for four weeks like in your
own Lea to be learning how to dance
together I mean you're obviously gonna
be creating a friendship and we had so
much fun and you know the set we laughed
the whole time and it was just like he's
such a doll he's such a great guy like
you just so when the Thai people you
just want to be around that we had
great time flash-forward and the couple
are mom and dad too little Everly and
have been treating us to adorable posts
and moments together over their
seven-year marriage I'm really blessed
man we got we have a little nice little
crazy Oh family like that super simple
Emma